good afternoon and thank
you this is actually
the one of a series of talks are we up
yes we are
up yeah about the mill architecture the
mill is much too novel and complex to be
summarized in just one talk and this is
a series you are there on the cash
hierarchy those ones which have already
been done um including the one here that
Andy mentioned and um our thanks to
Stanford for asking us to come back uh
those ones which have already been done
are available on our website there and
this and future ones will also wind up
being posted as
well
the particular topic is Cash
access there are a number of sub isues
involved in this you'll be uh I'll be
taking them one at a time they are
fairly independent of each other but
you'll see a Common Thread hooking
through
them however I must warn you that what I
have to say will be a gross
oversimplification of the way real chips
actually work the I'm attempting to
provide an intuitive understanding for
people who are not specialists in the
field if you are in fact a specialist
you know that I am lying through my
teeth and um please be patient with me
uh and consider the intended purpose if
you actually wish to get down into the
bitsies we've got bitsy answers for you
and feel free to ask about it
later first topic is referred loads and
I will explain that but first I must
mention where we're coming from this is
not a research project it's not an
academic product it's intended to be a
commercial chip consequently we must in
fact wind up being driven by the
marketplace and what the marketplace
wants out of a CPU is high execution
throughput low
power and
cheap fortunately how to provide that
for at least certain kinds of programs
has been well known for over 30 30 40
Years first your program needs to be
wide issue your architecture needs to be
wide issue if you're going to have high
execution throughput you need to be able
to have high parallelism and have a
whole stack of instructions that are
executed
simultaneously however in addition if
you're going to have low power you have
to get all of the what am I going to do
next get ready to to do it next do it
and uh then figure out what I'm going to
do after that logic which it consumes
90% of the performance of modern general
purpose chips like your x86 aswells for
example and coupled with static
scheduling you need to have an exposed
pipeline um for those two sort of come
together if you're in fact going to wind
up having a low power
environment you you can buy chips like
that today most vws for example and the
mill works the same
way to explain those
terms the mill is wide issue like a VW
or the itanium Epic
architecture um a single instruction
actually carries multiple operations um
how many the mill is is a processor
family and how many a particular
instruction uh can carry varies by the
particular family member here for
example we instruction carrying three
operations those operations will be
issued
simultaneously we only issue one
instruction but that means we're issuing
three operations in this
example the lexical ordering within the
instruction provides an ordering number
for the operations which are called
slots and Slots correspond to functional
unit pipelines in the execution Hardware
those pipelines are populated with
functional units adders multipliers
floating Point units load store what
have you but um each one of the
instruction slots corresponds to a
pipeline so that if you want to issue an
operation to a particular functional
unit it has to be in the slot of the
pipeline that that oper that functional
unit is
in the operations are
dispatched um torn out of the
instruction and sent to the indiv
individual pipelines who then proceed to
execute them an exposed pipeline means
that each operation has a known
statically known latency when we start
it now we know that it's going to be
done with its results available four
Cycles from now one cycle from now
whatever but always known thus for
example if we have that source code um a
sum minus of product well the sum and
product are independent of each other
and can be executed in parallel
simultaneously so the instruction for
that is going to have two operations an
ADD and a
multiply that will of course wind up
being uh linked to uh two functional
units an adder and a
multiplier and the dotted pink line
there means a cycle boundary in this and
future slides so um sometime after we
issue the ADD and the multiply we're
going to have results which are we're
now going to want to subtract so
there'll be a separate instruction with
a subtracted it there may be other
things as well but there'll be a
subtract for purposes of this code
fragment and a corresponding functional
unit one cycle later well we've got a
sum because an Adder takes one cycle but
the multiplier isn't done yet
multipliers are not one cycle operations
so it things are still in progress so we
have to go for another cycle and now the
multiplier is done and it's got its
result available those two results are
what we wanted for the subtractor so
those they flow into the subtractor and
that in turn gets us the result of our
final
operation now you notice the grade out
item there that says who holds this
that's a result which winds up being
just held because we're waiting for
other things to come out but there's no
really good reason to hold it instead
what we what you always really want is
to have your code so scheduled such that
the producer's results come out just in
front of when the first consumer wants
that value so what we really want is to
do that so that the multiply starts
early because it takes longer then the
ADD and then both results come out at
the same time they retire is the term
for the operation completing
and uh it will wind up going down into
the result available for the subtract
and we have our final result this
mechanism is called Static scheduling
with an exposed pipeline the mill works
that way there are lots of other trips
that work the same way commonly in the
embedded World stream processors lots of
things there's a catch there's always a
catch the catch is the exposed pipeline
only works if you reliably have a
statically known latency for every
operation because we've got to get
things put out in the right order so
that the issue comes out and the results
come out at the right
time not all operations have got a fixed
latency that is
recognizable the if the latency is not
statically knowable then the compiler
must assume the common case which is um
typically the optimistic case and if the
compiler is wrong then everything else
we have to stop issuing all other
operations until we actually have that
result um well we're wide machine so
stopping all other issues May mean that
we are um stopping issuing tens hundreds
of operations that we otherwise could
have done but it's doesn't work because
the timing turned out to be
wrong
ouch in practice the only varying
latency operation that matters is
load
now to to
show a bit of the detail about what we
do about it this problem I got to point
out a little bit about the hierarchy if
you have a operation and it hits in the
top level data cache
D1 um
why on most machines that'll take fre
Cycles or thereabouts between the load
and when the value has gone to the cash
been checked if you do translation uh
translation has been involved the value
has come back um the hardware Engineers
who do processors uh put Blood Sweat
Toil and tears into making that as fast
as possible because it is on the
critical path for all program execution
and they can get it down to three cycles
for many
architectures if the value you want is
not in the top level cash in order to
make it fast they make the top level
cash small which means very frequently
the value you want will not be there
there isn't enough room to keep all the
values you want so instead you go down
the one more layer to the second level
cache
D2 that's bigger but it also will take
10 typical Cycles to get a value back
out if it's not there
either well there may be still another
layer of cache but where you're seeing
the pattern here but eventually you'll
wind up um having checked all your
caches and you're going to wind up going
to
dram and that can be 300 Cycles
depending on exactly what it is that
your hook up and how lucky you were with
respect to the dam refresh
logic that is extremely painful if your
program has to do
that this is the load
problem when you write for example an
ADD and then a load and then a shift and
then a
store well that's your logical program
that's the order you want things to
happen because these operation need the
results of the operations in front of
them but what you actually get is an ad
a
load a stall a stall a stall for a
change another stall and finally the
value came back and you can do the shift
and the store and so
forth every architecture has this
problem they all must address
it
the are the goal is to hide load
latency there is a general strategy
which all architectures who attempt to
address this
follow you essentially ignore what the
program said and you issue operations as
soon as their data is
available you issue loads as early as
possible essentially as soon as the
address is
known or even earlier this is called
prefetch then you find something else to
do while you're waiting for the
data there are two strategies for
finding something else to do there's a
hardware approach called Dynamic
scheduling this is derived originally
from the tomasulo algor algorithm on the
36091 I see a whole lot of people around
the audience who like me we date from
that vintage and know what we're talking
about on the other hand if you look
inside a Haswell Mr thomasu would find
it very familiar in many
ways
um the alternative approach is a
software approach static scheduling with
exposed pipelines And Delay
slots the hardware approach with Dynamic
scheduling well the hardware decodes
ahead it's looking at the instructions
quite a long ways before when it
actually execute them and it buffers the
instructions that it decodes internally
that buffer is called the instruction
window if you hear me talking about
Windows later it tracks all the
operations whose data is not yet
ready when the operations do have their
data available and the hardware to
executed is available then it can issue
the
operations and as operations retire um
it updates those operations which might
have been waiting for that result um so
as to make them uh known to be issuable
as soon as corresponding Hardware is
available this is a good way of doing
things which is
why this laptop and most general purpose
machines work this
way the good news is that the strategy
can in fact hide latency those recycles
if you happen to hit in the top level
cash and it can hide at least some of
top level cash mishes mostly it can um
hide top level cash miss it can hide
some second level cach Miss Al though
typically it cannot hide 300 cycles of a
dam access but it can do essentially it
can hide everything that it can find
anything else to do um otherwise it will
stall the bad of it is that it's got
this narrow window that instruction
buffer is not very big it can't be made
very big for power and performance
reasons and it can only find it uh
operations to execute which are have
been decoded and are sitting in that
buffer there may be other operations in
the program that could have issued while
I was waiting for the data but it can't
because they're not in the
buffer the truly horrible thing about it
however is that it's extraordinarily
expensive in area and
power the software
approach the compiler does all the work
not the
hardware it determines dependencies
among operations it can look at the
entire program to do
so um rather than just a narrow window
it's schedules The Producers to retire
just before the consumer wants the
data it schedules independent operations
to issue
together and schedules loads under the
assumption that they will in fact hit in
the top level cach it assumes it assumes
a latency of three for those
loads the good side of that cheap low
power fast
Hardware there's no window limit can
look at the whole
program the
bad there's a limited load C
concurrency um I sh go into details
about that but typically it can't have
as many loads in Flight as the hardware
approach
can the ugly side of it is that if it's
wrong and we don't hit in the top level
cash we're not doing anything else we're
stopping issuing all operations waiting
for that value to come
back this is the load problem
except that in fact this is not the load
problem because there are in fact
several different load
problems if you take that load problem
apart you'll see that there's quite a
bit of different cases which are
relevant you need to look at if you're
going to attempt to have a
solution the simplest case is the case
that you can't do anything about some
loads will always miss to
damp if your program does nothing except
random accesses into a half table which
is bigger than cash you are going to be
pulling them from dram every single time
one 300 Cycles one 300 Cycles one 300
Cycles there's nothing that you the
hardware or the software can do about
this some loads must wait for data
dependent
addressing for example a link
list um if I want to chain down link
list well I have to go and get the
pointer to the next item and if that was
in if the link list is in Dam that's a
300 cycle weight I now have an address I
do another load and another 300 cycle
weight an address another load another
300 cycle weight and so
on
the there's been various proposals about
putting logic into uh smart memory and
putting it lodic out into dram we're a
commercial um operation and uh much as
we would like Samsung
to help us out here Samsung is not
willing to do this and the research in
this area is not working very
well no CPU as architecture has a good
solution to these
cases we don't
either excuse
me different category of pro load
problems some loads depend on control
FL take this
case um I'm assuming C from theity to
everyone this means um look at a and if
it's true you don't look at B if it's
false then you go look at B if B is
something that might fault or throw an
exception because it's a wild address or
something but a is good then you better
not go look at a until you got look at B
until you've gone and gotten a u because
the exception is in in fact not correct
and you should not be issuing the
corresponding
load this is not a load
problem this is a speculation problem
operations and most machines there is a
mechanism in which operations can be
issued speculatively the hardware does
not know the program does not know that
the operation is ever really going to be
used um but if we get it started early
so long as nothing bad happens um if it
turns out that we might need the result
and we turn out we do need the result
then by starting it early we're ahead
and if we didn't need it well all we
wasted is little power um the mill does
do
speculation however speculation is a
subject of a future talk in this series
we can only fit so much into an hour and
if you are interested in um hearing
about that talk you can sign up for our
mailing list which announces these talks
at that
Earl another
category some loads come in related
groups a classic example is iterating
over an
array um if each element of the array
you want to do something that doesn't
connect anything else just to that
element well you can load a whole pile
of them in in advance and hide the 300
cycles of the first one you you'll have
300 Cycles to get the first one but if
you can have three of them 300 of them
out there um you can just stream the
values in because the addresses are
known um this isn't a load problem
either this is a prefetch
problem the goal here is to have
everything started up and streamed ready
for you to per perform the fact that
it's done through a load operation is
irrelevant what you really want is a
stream of
data and M pre Mill prefetching is in
fact the subject of a future talk in
this series and you can in fact sign up
for the mailing list which will um get
you an invite to that
talk now we've eliminated a number of
cases which are either nobody can do
anything about or are different problems
so what's
left some loads are collections not of
related um operations not a bunch of
related loads but in fact are relatively
independent thus for example a plus b
plus C we can load A and B and C
simultaneously and we hope that they all
come back together um but if it turns
out that one of them has to go to Dam or
two of them have to go to D Ram we don't
have to do 300 plus 300 we can only do
300 and have um everything come back all
together so that's one
case another case is where you do
perfectly ordinary load and it misses in
the dcash top level dcash but it does
hit in the second level dcash and
because that's three Cycles versus 10
Cycles it took you an extra seven Cycles
you didn't anticipate and but you may
have seven ads or multiplies or what
have you that you can be doing in the
meantime um second
case it's a way to hide unexpected delay
of relatively small quantity of
unexpected delay um both hardware and
software approaches may be able to find
seven operations to perform but it's not
going to find 200 operations to perform
while waiting for a a uh Dam
head outof order hand Hardware handles
both of these cases and handles it very
well but only these
cases this is a quote I love the Dirty
Little Secret of out of order is how
little out of order there actually is
the source of this quote is Andy glue
who some of you may know who he is but
he was responsible for the
um the architecture of both AMD and
Intel CPUs and is now at myips and
invented one of the mechanisms one of
the two standard mechanisms for doing
out of order in his PhD thesis and is um
amongst the kenti is a recognized
wizard he's at Intel no he's at MEPS
now he's been he's been at MEPS for over
a
year
um Mill Sol the mill solution is called
a deferred load we've given you what the
background is now we tell you what we do
about
it a generic Mill load
operation you of course have an OP code
load you have an argument which is an
address the mill has got a bunch of
address modes there nothing greatly
surprising about that there's a 64-bit
Base address a up to 32 bid offset and
optionally a scaled
index um so plain so
common you also have to say how wide a
thing you want um the mill supports 1
two 48 and 16 byte
loads um or vectors of each of those and
so you have to say what it is that you
want here's where things get strange
there's another argument called the
delay
this is the number of issue Cycles which
the hardware must wait until retiring
the result of the
load if you spit in three the hardware
is required to return the result in
three Cycles if it can't return the
result in three Cycles you will have
stalls if you put in seven it Returns
the result in seven Cycles so the
program is explicitly controlled in the
retire
time so the load issues
here we do another
instruction we do another
instruction and a still a fourth
instruction and
now that's where the load
retires the consumer can be in the
following
cycle its data is available there how do
we know that the data is going to be
available because the load operation
said retire is deferred for for
instructions now to compare this against
the usual way of doing
things when there's nothing to do but
wait we've got a load and there's no
other operation which is available that
can be done while in until we get the
result back from the
load we assume that there are no
independent operations
available well the static approach is
going to have the load and because the
static knows that it's going to take
three Cycles there'll be two noops in
the code because otherwise it doesn't
know the two cycles have gone by typical
vliw will have no Ops in the these cases
these are delay slot operations you I
may mention
the dynamic
case will issue the load it doesn't need
no Ops but we're assuming that we hit in
the top level cash there will be two
cycles of
stall the mill with deferred operations
will issue the load because it's
statically scheduled it also has to say
we're going to to idle for two cycles
worth of noops and the retire is there
one difference between the the static
and the Deferred form despite the fact
that all three have got the same
performance the m noops in the encoding
occupy no extra space in the code stream
mil noops have zero bits in nearly all
cases um and if you want to know how
that works that was actually covered in
the first talk that was given here last
May and the details are available at
that Earl on our website you can go to a
look at the um video to see how it's
done yes so is that unfair because you
have a two in the load that has to be
represented again please there there's a
two in your load the delay number that
says we have to delay for two but that
cost you some bits oh the delay cost you
a few bits yes that's true but that's
per load not per delay
slot
now
so much for the case where we don't have
anything else to do now assume that
there are enough operations to hide the
D1 latency and in fact that we hit in
the D1 this example we assume that there
are five independent operations
available the static case can only set
two of them because it the static will
always have a latency of three but
they're five operations so it will
schedule the load followed by five
operations the retire value will in fact
retire between Op 2 and op three but
that doesn't make any difference because
we've got other things to do and the
fact that it did retired then doesn't
matter or is
irrelevant the dynamic case it's
essentially the same thing it has five
operations to do um it will retire
earlier than the fifth one but it's
going to be busy doing the other
operations anyway so the fact they
retired early does doesn't matter the
referred case is going to say well I've
got five independent operations so I
will schedule my retire to happen after
the fifth
operation and it will then perform of
the five independent operations the
value could have been retired earlier
but was not it was retired after the
fifth all three have the same
performance now we come to the case when
things are different here we have those
same five operations but we miss in the
D1 the static
case well it schedules the load followed
by the two operations that knew about
but then it will stall at least three
Cycles um and perhaps more the double
yellow line there means an unknown
number of of Cycles if we happen to go
to uh
dram eventually retirement but it's only
actually executed two with the possible
five at the point of retire when it
picks up again the dynamic case can do
better than that it can in fact get all
five done before it has to stop and wait
for the value to come from wherever the
value is coming from and picks up with
the
retire the mill deferred in
coding will have scheduled all five
will'll do all five at that point point
that the value is not available yet we
too will wait waiting for the value to
come back and we will at that point
retire so the Deferred case is the same
as dynamic in terms of timing and both
are better than
static reordering of your code can give
you more opportunity to hide these
stalls you manually can rewrite the
program or the compiler can do it for
you or the hard work in reorder
operations so long as program sematics
are
maintained so for example if that's the
initial code um
and that actual code is an operation
there to hide one stall so there will be
a second stall even if we do hit in the
L1 but loads can be hoisted over prior
operations they can be
moved
and like that we now have two operations
between the load and its consumer so
we're hiding two stalls if we hit in um
the D1 there will be no stalling at
all in addition consumers may be lowered
over later
operations we now have got three in
between the load and the consumer that
hides three
stalls their
constraints you can't hoist a consumer
over its producer that you have to
preserve data flow
order but you also have to look out for
side
channels there's two important
categories of side channels one is that
loads and stores can communicate through
memory and the other is operations can
communicate through exception handling
if um the program it may be important
that any except ceptions are delivered
in program
order I won't address exceptions
exceptions are the subject of another
talk um the hard the problem of going
through memory this talk is about memory
the problem of going through
memory is um if the if loads and stores
refer to the same address obviously a
load a store referring to different
addresses um that are not communicating
and uh in general can be reordered but
if they go to the same address well you
can't hoist a load over a store or
you'll get the former value where what
you're supposed to get is the later
Value Hardware knows whether it's the
same address or not one of the
advantages the hardware Dynamic
scheduling the software approach does
not know whether it's the same address
it can tell sometimes but all too
frequently it cannot tell um because the
the two addresses May Alias they may
overlap and um in the case when the
hardware winds up finding that they
don't overlap but the compiler cannot
prove that they don't overlap this is
called false aliasing and is a source of
considerable inefficiency in pointer
heavy code like most of your C and
C++ so eliminate
aliasing loads see memory as of a
snapshot in
time all stores which take effect prior
to that snapshot in time it can see all
stores which take effect after that
snapshot of time as far as the load is
concerned did not do not
happen the mill defines that loads see
memory as of the Mills retire cycle not
where the load operation itself is is
issued but where it
retires the in instruction Load
7 yes it means deliver the result after
seven
Cycles but it also means deliver the
result as it will be after seven
instructions this gives Alias
immunity
load issue may be hoisted over stores
including stores at Alias because the
issue is
irrelevant the only thing that matters
is the
retire if this is your original code
with a load in consumer down there at
the bottom and a bunch of stores prior
to
it there's the retire and because
there's no in space in between the load
and the consumer there'll be a few
stalls in there and we actually execute
this code
copying that over and modifying it
there's there the same code but now
we're going to lift the load up ho
it
suddenly we now have got six
instructions that we can be operating on
in parallel and it does not matter if
those stores are to the same address as
the load because the load is seeing
memory as of the retire site
these are the same
sematics and the same value
loaded loads can cross control
flow it's important that the control
flow however have the same number of
Cycles between the issue load and the
retire
if I have an if then else that diamond
there is an if then else and we do did a
load of nine cycles and if the then and
the else are both six Cycles well it
doesn't matter which way the control
flow went it's what we're doing is we're
counting the number of instructions
issued and we'll get the retire there
nine Cycles after the load was issued if
on the other hand the then and the else
have got two different timings 6 versus
3 for example if we go down the uh six
side well we'll retire there but if we
go down the three side we would retire
there that's not going to
work so instead we have Define what we
call pickup
loads a pickup load operation looks very
much like a deferred load operation you
have an OP code you have an address you
have a width but instead of a
delay you supply a program selected name
which identifies this particular
load the load issues there the example
uses T5 for a name
it there is an instruction some number
of
instructions and then we execute another
operation called
pickup with the same
name the pickup acts as the retire for
that
load the retire the load retires
there it's available for the
consumer it does not matter what control
flow there was between the load and its
retire or how many cycles there was in
between we're not going to do anything
until the corresponding pickup gets
executed
the pickup load issues
there the retire is deferred until the
matching pickup is
executed and we're
done the compiler strategy for getting
this kind of code into a code
stream it's actually quite simple most
wide issue machines use time reverse
schedule eding and we do too you
schedule the code in time reverse order
you decide where the consumers are first
and then you schedule the producers for
that and then treat the producer as a
consumer and schedule the producers for
that and so forth so scheduling is done
in time reverse order although the
resulting binary will be executed in
time forward
order the schedules produced retire
immediately in front of the first
consumer of its
value you schedule the longest latency
data flow in internally to the compiler
first that'll give you your best code
and the shortest overall
latency you Hoist the load issue to
immediately after where the address is
produced for many loads this the address
is statically known and you don't have
to do to um you can hoist it all the way
to the the top of the function for
example if you're loading out of the the
stack
frame um if it turns out that there's
fewer than the minimum number of um
Cycles in between the load issue and the
load retire you may have to add a few
noops and when you've got that you
figure out how many cycles there are in
between the load and its retire and
that's the delay that you put in the
corresponding load operation this
algorithm is straightforward it's quasi
linear and is real easy in the
compiler the
tradeoff in out of order well you can
hide parts of some
misses and parts of all the misses you
can hide it is immune to false
aliasing but you got complex and power
hungry
Hardware static
scheduling a Miss stalls instruction
issue you cannot resolve false
aliasing but you got simple and
economical
Hardware the mill we hide the same
misses as out of
order we are also immune to false
aliasing but we have SIMPLE and
economical
Hardware now I said when we start that
we wouldn't talk much about
implementation but this needs at least a
word or two about how um those work on
the
inside each Mill family member defines a
number of retire stations um these are
Hardware units containing
buffers let's assume that the family
member has got that number of retire
stations the load
operation that load operation
we first allocate a
station it'll then unpack the arguments
of the load into the
station and there's a data
buffer in parallel with this we send a
request to the memory hierarchy for that
width number of bytes at that
address in order to implement the fact
that we are having data as of retire
cycle we have to see if there were in
fact any um aliasing
stores while we're in the process of
doing all this so when the store when
they a store a functional unit um
handles aore store operation it Con
converts that into a store request which
is sent to the
D1 and there's your store functional
unit and there's the D1 that we're going
to send
to
Meanwhile any active retire stations are
monitoring the stream of store requests
looking for
aliases there's probably some inactive
stations but the active stations are
going to be looking at the store
requests as they Flow
by if they hit that is if there's a
matching or overlapping
address the station discards any
buffered data that it has and requests
the
load that re request will'll see the
result of the
store guess what that's a semantics we
want it that the loads see the results
as of the retire cycle and if in fact
there is aliasing and true aliasing is
very rare um in in real Code false
aliasing is unfortunately rather
prevalent but true aliasing is rare but
you look and well you got to reissue it
and that may take a little extra time
but people who do aliasing deserve that
anyway um
those of you who are familiar with the
insides of the way lot and store buffers
work on a super scaler will know about
um monitoring store streams this
mechanism is essentially the same
implementation except that there are the
substantially fewer retire stations than
there are load and store
buffers when it reissues that request
that request goes down to the
D1 and the value will go back up to the
retire station which is now still
monitoring and May in fact need to
discard its data and rquest it yet
again if it's
unlucky retire stations get
allocated by the
hardware the stations are frame local
each function logically has its own
set of course they don't have a physical
set there's a fixed number of physically
the physical stations are dynamically
allocated loads from different frames
may be inlight
concurrently so if that's a stack
frame and that green frame uh issues two
loads it will have allocated two retire
stations which may retire quite some
time in the future meanwhile we do a
call new stack
frame the new stack frame the pink one
may do its own loads and Al at a couple
of retire stations and do a
call note these calls may be interrupts
for
too um the blue one now does its own
couple of loads we've got a whole bunch
of ones now in flight but the blue one
wants to do yet another load it thinks
it's got a full set of eight it doesn't
know that somebody else is using any of
them so non-local stations that is non
blue in this example wind up being
spilled the we pick one that pink one is
now turned
red and the pink aspect of it winds up
going to the Spiller which is a mill
Hardware State saave engine which is
running in parallel with everything else
that's going
on um and the red has now been
reallocated to
Blue we only spill the address and the
width and the
delay we do not spill the buffer
contents
instead when the return happens we
reallocate a retire station and request
the
load consequently we are able to
prefetch across calls because when that
um uh return happens the value the
original load may have gone all the way
to dram but in in addition to returning
a value we're not using it will have
loaded the cach line into cach so
effectively it's acting as a
prefetch fine
print there are in fact a few rare cases
in which a hardware Dynamic allocator
can find things to do that the mill
algorithm cannot find it is an exercise
for the student to figure out such an
example a hint is that these mostly
involve cascaded load operations they
are fact rare in code but they do exist
and it's left as an
exercise on the other hand because the
mill is doing static scheduling it's got
a complete view of the entire program
and can find operations that can be
issued in parallel which the um Hardware
unit which is restricted only to the
instruction window cannot find this
effect is also relatively
small the
do
delay I'm sorry I'm slightly deaf and I
can't hear that at all with the delay
when you spill a
load um the delay remains unchanged
you're only you're only counting um
Cycles within the frame that issued the
load we're not counting Cycles within
the called bodies so so it's not correct
to think of the delay as representing
some sort of a fixed point in the
instruction space it's a fix point with
respect to the code of that
function call is one instruction the
call the call is one instruction no
matter how long the sub routine takes
yes the call counts as one
instruction
um these two effects are both minor and
they're offsetting so do a first
approximation the mill memory access is
essentially equivalent in performance to
the dynamic out of order super scaler
which this laptop
uses
um however the power and um area and
complexity cost is vastly
less another issue matter of fine
print retire stations at are spilled
across functional calls or tasks which
get reallocated and reloaded I
mentioned the original load will in fact
have um brought the line into dram
typically though it may wind up getting
kicked out depending on how complicated
that call
was and in fact Branch prediction logic
can anticipate that the factor return is
going to happen and get the the um
reissued requests started ahead even
before the return happens the branch
predictor may be wrong but that doesn't
matter um because we're just simply
going to toss away the reissues
anyway so much for
loads however memory costs are not
restricted to loads there's a thing
called a stor
miss you excuse
me when a program writes to
memory and the line is not in Cache that
it's writing
to traditional architectures have got
two possible things they could
do they could take the new data and
write it directly to
Dam this is called right
through
alternatively they can issue what
amounts to a load a read to bring in the
cach line and then once the cach line is
in then they can simply update it as if
it' been there there from the beginning
this is called right back
either way that store has to be
buffered it occupies uh memory traffic
and B
bandwidth and it's a fair amount of arm
waving and power cost within the logic
to handle
it not on a
mill on a
mill every bite in the caches is nine
bits long they're eight data bits and
one bit that tells you whether the eight
data bits are
meaningful a validity
bit when you do a
store and you put a value into that bite
the store supplies the eight datab bits
and the fact that they've been stored
into sets the valid
bit if you allocate a new cach line that
has not yet been stored all of the btes
are
invalid so for example
let's say we're storing eight bytes
containing the first part of hello world
now that's not the actual store syntax
it's purely for
illustration and there's no cash
line well when there's no cash line we
will in fact allocate in Hardware a cash
line in the top level
cash and the X's there mean that in fact
they're all
invalid
that value now gets written we now have
valid data eight bytes of it and the
remaining bytes remain
invalid now assume that there's an
interrupt
interrupts do a lot of code and
frequently they their code will be
enough to uh pretty much scrub your top
level cache and the data the dirty data
that's in the top level cache will be
moved down into the second level
cash like
so note that the validity has remained
unchanged it's still got eight bytes
that are valid and the remainder
invalid now the interrupt is done we're
back to the main program and we do
another store for the second half of our
hello world note that the address is now
offset by
eight well there isn't any cash line for
it in the top level cash
so we allocate a cash
line
and we write to it we now have a line
for this address in two different
caches these are two cach lines but they
refer to the same location in the
address
space once that's set up of course you
may want to read the value back so we'll
do a load and when you issue a load the
request actually contains besides the
line address it contains a mask of the
btes that you want to return derived
from the length of the original
request so if we do a load and say that
what we want is in fact um offset into
the value we just read uh just U have
written well we'll allocate a retire
station we'll create a request with a
mask
and send that request down to the top
level
cach the top level cach will find the
corresponding line if it's there which
it is in this case and see if there's
any overlap between the valid bits of
The Cash Line and the request the mask
bits and the request in this
case there
are and those bytes get returned to the
retire station only those B
but notice we still have some green
requests we still have not satisfied our
entire request the remainder um need to
be passed down the cash hierarchy to
look at the next level cash where again
we wind up checking to see if there is
any overlap between the valid bits in
the line and the request bits there is
and those values get returned to the
retire station now all of the request
bits are satisfied we can simply discard
the request no need to go any further
although if there were some still left
we wouldn't fact go further ultimately
down into
d a retire station is now satisfied and
the load can
retire any line in this process that is
hit that supplies any valid bite will
automatically be copied up one level in
the hierarchy so in this case we hit in
both lines in both caches the D1 is
already at the top of the hierarchy but
we'll copy the D2 cach line that we hit
in up and merge its
data the rule for merger is at the top
valid bite wins it's the obvious way of
doing
things as a result it is impossible for
the mill to store Miss stores are always
by definition satisfied in the top level
cash we don't have store buffers we
don't have um all of the arm wavings of
right
through it goes directly to
cash
now well this takes care of a fair
amount of the problems of load and of
store by far the cheapest form of memory
access is the memory access you didn't
do in the first
place so let's take a look at some of
those cases and to do that I have to
give you a bit of a picture of the what
the cash hierarchy looks like at
extremely t top
level there's a CPU core of
course and um it's got load store
functional units and it's got retire
stations
and we're a Harvard architecture so
there's a data cache and the load store
functional unit send requested the data
cache and the data cach returns results
to the retire
stations as a Harvard architector
there's also an instruction side there's
a um for reasons which you can see if
you look at our first um Talk on our
website that was given here last may we
actually have two instruction caches and
um there's even a micro cach higher up
irrelevant to this talk but I needed to
have it actually reflect
reality there's a shared level too where
Harvard only at the top
level
so all of those values may flow from the
level two up to the respective level one
caches below the level two cache we're
only level two in these examples you
could have a level three cache that's
entirely a configuration issue
the device
controllers which feed to and from the
level two cache and they are in turn are
hooked to a level of
devices so far so
commonplace however you and I should
mention that the actual organization is
mem dependent but
typical one thing you may have noticed
that ear not mentioned here is
translation and the translation look
aide buffer which is present in um your
memory
hierarchy we do have a
tlb it's
there those of you who are chuckling
know that this is not where it usually
is in addition we have something that
most machines don't have called
protection look aide buffers and there
are in fact two of them one on the data
side and one on the instruction side and
they are there
the protection looker side buffer is
refer um essentially a cache over a
protection control tables maintained by
the operating system just like the
translation lookaside buffer is a cash
over translation tables maintained by
the operating
system commonly um protection and
translation is done together on a
machine like this but not on the
mill because of this organization the
mill users virtual caching rather than
physical
caching and it uses the single address
space model rather than having multiple
address spaces is one statically Global
shared by everybody address
space everything within the blue dotted
line uses virtual
addresses everything within that blue
dot is
line uses physical
addresses now to compare the models the
traditional
model program addresses must be
translated to physical addresses before
they can be looked up in cash because
the cash uses physical addressing so a
load operation passes a virtual address
to the tlb the tlb turns it into a
physical address which goes to a cache
which return lines to uh the
CPU the tlb is doing both translation
and protection if the protection fails
you'll get a fault a
trap on the
mill all the tasks you're using virtual
addresses there is no
aliasing across Tas of the OS so load
operation actually sends the request to
two different entities one it sends
directly to the cach translation is not
required and data gets returned to the
CPU simultaneously and in parallel it
sends the same request to the protection
buffer and if the protection fails uh we
will get a fault just like anybody else
um but that fault uh is done in such a
way that the data that would otherwise
have been pulled never does actually get
back to the
CPU it's done in parallel with the
request in the
cash this critter
the
tlb is a
bottleneck because it's squarely in the
middle of the of the critical path it is
vital that it be exceptionally
fast fast means high
power fast means
small consequently TR tlb misses or
common
place
and well
it's
painful the reason why it's used is for
historical
reasons back when there were only 32-
bit address spaces
but computers started having multiple
programs running whose cumulative total
address space across all programs was
more than 32 bits would hold well you're
screwed and the solution was to give
each program it own 32-bit address space
distinct from the physical address space
used and translate everything from the
program's own idea of what a particular
address bit pattern meant to what the
hardware meant by a particular one that
translation is the
tlb this is no longer relevant in a
64-bit address
space you can fit lots and lots of
programs with lots and lots of stuff in
bits the
cost it's the critical path it's power
hungry it's small so it has to be
multiple leveled and real programs as
opposed to benchmarks frequently are
spending as much as a quarter of their
entire processing time dealing with
tlb why put translation after the
cash
well the T is out of the critical path
in particular you're only going to go to
the tlb if you miss in cash which means
that 95% of all the loads and stores are
never going to go to the
tlb
consequently it can be
big it can be low
power and if we're going to the tlb it
means we missed in cash and what's going
to happen next is a 300 cycle Dam
weight so consequently if we take a
cycle or two extra
to um be economical in our TB well 300
versus 302
Cycles nobody
cares a side
benefit is that everybody uses has the
same meaning for a given bit pattern in
a
pointer consequently if you want to pass
a pointer between programs or most
importantly a pointer between a program
and the operating system the bit pattern
means exactly the same for both sender
and
receiver the two may have different
permissions one may say I have the
rights to use this bit pattern the other
may not but they mean the same place
consequently you don't have to do any
translation when you're sending these
things across it turns out that on many
machines and many operating systems the
operating systems winds up spending a
truly amazing quantity of time handling
system calls that take pointers things
like reads and writes and getting them
translated to what the operating system
thinks is the corresponding address not
at all necessary
on protection checking can be done in
parallel
it's
easy now when we allocate
memory on a conventional machine an
allocation like a me map which is if
you're speak
Unix um when we allocate a
megabyte it does not actually allocate
physical
memory what it does is it allocates
address
space but it has to record the fact that
it's allocated this and the way it
records that fact is it maintains a page
table private to the operating
system and that page table is full of
pte or page table entries one for each
page that says this hunk of um address
space is in fact U Been allocated it
belongs to this program and because we
haven't allocated any physical memory we
are saying that this page is unrealized
it's not yet backed by any physical
memory
this is a good thing because backing
things by physical memory is expensive
but the operating system sets up its
page table in
map
when we do a store into the situation
bear in mind there's no physical memory
again that store is going to go first
time through remember translation is in
front of cash so we can't look at Cash
yet so we go to the to the trans look
aside buffer the tlb the tlb will not
find anything in there and so it
consults the OS page tables and it will
find an entry in the page tables and it
will find that it is
unrealized it will then cause the store
to trap into the operating
system there's no physical memory
somebody's got to get me some physical
memory because stores always will go
wind up going to physical memory and the
cashes will use a physical memory read
address the OS winds up allocating a
physical
page
there zeros it which takes quite a long
while because it has to go actually to
dram for all of this
stuff you notice it takes a
while updates the a the page table entry
to the corresponding physical address
that's now turned green to indicate it's
correct fixes that the page table entry
and returns from the trap and the store
can now
proceed all is Happy except for the
person who is looking at the
clock on the
mill well we don't create page table
entries instead by definition any
address space that is not covered by a
page table entry is
unrealized the m map well there's still
a page table for those thing Pages which
have had places allocated for them but
the M map allocates the address space
but nothing gets put into the page
table we now do a
store well remember stores don't go to
memor stores only go to the top level
Cache no involvement with a
tlb um we don't have to find a page
table
entry there's no Associated physical
memory and the address space is backless
this is backless memory things that live
entirely in cash not in Dam there's
never even been dram
allocated if however the program does a
no no and loads a value that never got
written it will miss in cash because
it's never gotten
written so we do issue a
load
the load store functional unit does its
thing we will check to see if we have
permissions for this area the PB will
check and we'll say that it's
okay we will look in the dll one the the
uh top level data cache nope no such
luck we'll then look in this is the
request flowing down that you saw
earlier on we'll look in the second
level of data cache nope
we'll Now find the page table entry
which involves looking in the tlb just
like anybody else and when we the tlb
won't find it but it'll look in the page
table and it won't find a page table
entry either there isn't
one at this point without going to
Dam we've got a retire
station the tlb returns a
zero
directly that is
a Miss to backless memory implicitly
defines that backless memory is already
zero we didn't have to allocate it we
didn't have to initialize it we simply
load Miss into it oh this thing is
backless have a
zero the retire station has a zero up
the value goes when it times out or the
pickup happens and away we go there is
no access to
Dam the other side of accessing dram is
an evict bear in mind the stores only go
to the top level but eventually cash
gets busy and we wind up evicting dirty
values that have to be written
back
well um that eviction there's all you'll
always pick a victim that victim of
course will be in the second level cash
because that's things to get written out
so we select the least recently used
line standard algorithm and let's say
it's that
line we'll search for a page table entry
guess what there ain't
one so at that point we have to allocate
a physical page we are in fact going to
put things out into Dam we need a
physical
page and let's say that that is the
physical page which you
allocate we update the page
table by adding a new page table entry
which refers to our new data our new um
physical
memory we copy the data to
memory we discard the cach line the one
we just
evicted and that cash Line is now usable
by somebody else is that allocation of
the main memory of an OS
function all steps are in
Hardware what happens in in case of
memory map inut output so if I store to
memory map save it until after the talk
otherwise I'm going to run into time
trouble I I will
answer um there are no traps to the
OS fine print of course you knew there
was going to be fine
print the way this works the way the
hardware is able to do it
is that we use a hierarchical page table
which is a common mechanism in which you
have different Siz pages but uniquely we
support Pages which are one line
long the hardware allocates out of a bit
map of a bunch of oneline pages which
are all
contiguous Hardware allocates that of
bit Maps real
well if it's succeeds in running out of
its bit
map then the hardware will allocate from
a list of available other blocks which
has got Associated bit
Maps if it runs out of
blocks it triggers a
trap however there's a background OS
process which is make sure that the
Hardware's lists of blocks is um full
enough that actually running out is a
rare
event that's backless
memory that takes care of many memory
things but not all of
them a large quantity of
the um memory accesses for
everyone is stack
frames probably the major majority of
all memory references for everything
except high performance Computing and uh
benchmarks
um many of those references are
initialization and much of that
initialization is to
zero when a stack frame
exits all the lines in the frame are
garbage they are dead
but they will be in dirty in cash and if
that we don't wind up reusing the space
of that frame those will wind up being
evicted back out to dram even
pointlessly because they're dead they're
meaningless access to uninitialized data
is a common
bug and a common exploit is to browse in
the rubble left by exited stack
frames you look up in your stack and
there may be what was left of a frame
that was doing password validation and
in the memory there is the password in
clear and if you just simply go and look
there you'll find things you're not
supposed to this is a common source of
exports the implicit zero
you've got a data stack Stacks screw up
in this
example on the mill you allocate a stack
frame with explicitly with the stack F
operation it takes an argument which is
the amount of space You Want To Have and
that is in units of
lines so stack F of four says I want
four lines worth of a new
frame simultaneously there is a bit map
the implicit zero bit map with one bit
for each of these
lines
there
and we associate one bit with each of
the new lines these are bits are clear
they're
false
now if we do a load from an implicit
zero
line as for example in that case we have
a retire station we send a request down
there it looks at the bit map and it
says
no this has no
data it returns a
zero we didn't have to initialize it you
unconditionally will get a
zero you can't browse in rubble you'll
get a
zero if you do a store to an implicit
zero it writes a
data there's a store
request writes the
data sets the all of the bytes of the
rest of that line remember it's a new
line to
zero and sets the
bit subsequent
loads will look at the bit and say oh
this line has
been realized and we'll actually go and
look at the cash hierarchy for the
line a return
operation discards all realized lines in
the frame that you're returning
from so we've got one realized line here
that
um is there we execute the return it is
that line is discarded in the course of
cutting back the stack we we um reset so
those lines are no longer part of the
stack we
also reset the corresponding bits in
that bit
mask the realized lines are
discarded in in fact what we wind up
doing is we just simply clear all the
valid bits
um consequently they will not be written
back to DM we also clear the Dirty
Bit you knew there was going to be fine
print compiler optimization can
recognize the fact that things are being
initialized with zero and simply skip
that
instruction you don't have to it's going
to be
zero however the this greatly
confuses um initialization error
detecting tools like purify or
valr um so those have to be modified to
run on a mill so that they are aware of
the existence of an implicit
zero otherwise they will give you errors
all over
everything it could be impli it could be
used for other um kinds of allocation we
do not there's been some discussion
about using it for the active allocation
point in the garbage collecting system
but maybe
someday the bit mask covers all of the
lines at the top of the stack and
obviously it rotates with the stack in
in the obvious way um consequently it
may um cover lines which are cover more
than one stack uh more than one stack
frame um a typical implicit zero mask
will be 64 bits covering the top 6 four
lines of the Mask which may be a number
of different frames um as calls happen
the um the mask rotates so it's always
covering the top lines of the
mask of of the
stack
um you can ask for a stack frame which
is bigger than those 64 lines in that
case um all the ones which are not
covered by the implicit zero register
are immediately um
uh allocated and initialized and
realized um by the stack of operation
itself it just AO just generates the
necessary numbers of of dummy
stores a task switch forces realization
of
everything there's complications of
implicit zero if you're running in a
mold cor if um because the memory does
not reflect what the running core with
the implicit is going to see um if some
other core has the ability to look at
memory underneath it it will see the
values that should be that are should be
zero but are not because it's looking at
real memory the hardware has mechanisms
to handle this moldic cor is however a
um topic of another talk um in this
series which we invite you to come in
here
lastly memory consistency is an issue
whether you are taking a long time for
your loads and stores or a short time
for your loads and stores because memory
consistency leads to memory consistency
bugs and um frequently very painful and
slow operations to ensure
consistency if the program says that for
an
example that's a semantic order whatever
the program said that is the defines the
sematics of the execution of the
program and the time order of execution
defines the semantic order of the
program The Mill is a wide issue machine
so this turns into
instructions and let us say that both
loads and the store were in um wind up
being put into the same instruction
which they could
be and there is a semantic ordering in
slot order for the wide
issue it is the compiler's job to turn
to make sure that it um encodes the
operations in the slots in the same
order as the program is specified so we
know that the slot zero load must be the
load one on the left hand side because
it has to be before the store and the
load in slot two on the right hand side
must be the one load two which is after
the store in order to preserve sematic
order
now we now have sematic ordering within
an
instruction that instruction winds up
being distributed out to functional
units during decode as explained at the
very
beginning and those wind up going out to
the functional units in slot
order consequently there we are now
defining a semantic order within the
functional units as they execute in fact
physically they may be running in
parallel but the visibility between
units is ordered in that same semantic
order those functional units issue
requests those requests will wind up
going down to
cache and they request defines a request
order which is also the same semantic
order as from the
beginning but Lo are as
of
instruction quite true and if I could
put all of that on a slide I
would
no no it there is a defined order take
it take it after I finish I I'm soon to
finish okay so we have a defined order
here in the cache and they may get
satisfied and things may go down further
but they too will wind up retaining the
order consequently top to bottom from
the original
program all the way down through
instructions functional units requests
and data there is no
overtaking nothing is done out of the
original order
this is called sequential consistency
and is universally regarded as the most
intellectually
understandable um memory model and
organization but it only applies within
a monore within a single
core there are no membar instructions
which are commonly required if you do
not have Hardware sequential consistency
membar is extraordinarily expensive and
very very hard to get right
there are no memory race
bugs if you are in fact running in a
multicore you have a cache coherence
protocol moldic cor is the topic of
another
talk and um one of the aspects that will
be covered in that talk is the fact that
our cache coherence protocol merges the
sequential consistency of each core into
a globally sequentially consistent
ordering across all courts how it does
that is 15 minutes with the slides so
you won't get it t
today however interestingly enough due
to other aspects some of which were
touched on
today the resting cash coherence
protocol runs roughly twice the speed of
a the cash coherence protocol on a
conventional and cash go protocols on a
um High count multicore or can consume
an awful lot of your performance and
power you can sign up at that Earl for
an invitation to that
talk
summaries it'll hide cash latency and
cash misses to the extent that it can be
done because we have there are in fact
operations so the performance is like
outof order Hardware and the power cost
is like static scheduling it is immune
to false
aliasing it will implicitly prefet
across interrupts and function
calls doesn't need to zero initialize
stack frames doesn't write back dead
frames prevents uninitialized frame
bugs has no store buffers as opposed to
50 odd on something like a has well
at extraordinary cost stores go to cash
directly eliminates a great majority of
tlb
references shared address space
simplifies the operating
system backlist data needs no physical
Pages um if you allocate a hung of
memory use
it deallocate it there may never be any
memory at all and the OS is never
involved uniform sequential consistency
throughout I think didn't I mention that
you could sign
up thank you
[Applause]
folks